you're the creator of Mozart in the
jungle yes this star is I want to say
this name correctly it's it's GAE L Gayo
Gayo guy L Garcia Bernal yes yes and I
think we have a picture of guy al Garcia
Bernal you know that man yeah that's a
handsome man right that is a very
handsome fellow right there and what was
it like working because you you know
you're you're you're trying to inspire
him you're trying to work with him
you're the creator yeah well I've never
created anything by of my children but
I've never created and decide that I'm
glad your children aren't here for that
yeah yeah I never really created I mean
you guys created you yeah you gonna tell
besides you yeah no I I you know but one
of the creators of the show and yeah to
have this kind of talents incredible and
but he's a you know he's a real
superpower and a handsome strong man and
I feel like quite the opposite of that
and I was on the set one day looking
around just thinking about something not
probably negative about you know about
about how things were you know myself
and I feel these hands like well we can
you turn around can I show you something
okay I'll just show you it's probably
easier to do like you're me look I'm you
and I'm looking around and I feel like
this oh okay
and I don't like that kind of move you
don't maybe you don't like it I I'm
liking it
so I kill that and then I start to feel
this he starts rubbing your belly yeah
yeah hey buddy stop come on so I'll talk
you through the rest this boy start
rubbing he starts rubbing your belly so
I go well who's that
any other hats meow and hello hi and
then he he jiggled my study went like
whoa it was a weird day and then I said
hey come on come on and then he grabbed
my sides and he goes oh you've got the
wisdom handles wait he grabs the yeah
yeah small roll of fat you may have the
tiny roll of fat tiny because the rest
of its below my yeah you got the part
that popped up and so he's like oh
you've got the wisdom handles and it's
like hey I you what we all do and I grab
him and he's just hard muscle just tight
sexually smell that power
yeah so so uh but it was that's the kind
of thing that I got to do this
this summer in New York but so yeah it's
a great show
[Applause]
it's your project that's the kind of
stuff that goes into the project that
kind of energy translates
you